hi guys I'm so happy to talk to you both
today for the show um first Jennifer if
I may I just wanted to say I have been
one of your biggest fans since I was 16.
Alias meant everything to me it was like
I I cannot even put into words how much
that show meant to me growing up and how
much it gave me so much confidence too
so thank you for me from all the fans
who felt the same way about that show
much it's so kind of you thank you were
you surprised to see Victor yeah I was I
was I was freaking out about it my
sister and I watched the show together
and we were just so happy to see it was
such a lovely reunion but I will get to
that in these questions and I'm so happy
to talk to both of you this show has
been phenomenal it is a brilliant edger
seat mystery I loved it so much
um you know first question you know what
was it like you know having this type
these two types of characters because I
feel like this was nothing that you guys
have ever portrayed before Hannah and
Bailey like what was the attraction
behind those characters and angry if you
would love to answer first yes um for me
the thing that really intrigued me about
Bailey is she's so certain of who she is
and what she wants but her identity is
tied to just one person and that's her
dad and so when that disappears
she has to she she questions everything
about who she is everything about what
she loves and and how she defines
herself it all goes away so I was really
interested in exploring the Journey of a
girl who is in crisis mode and almost in
this set in this constant state of
anxiety and um and fear of the unknown
um that was really interesting to me and
to see it all happen in real time it it
feels so immediate and so
urgent
um and I I I was so excited to get into
that headspace this is a completely
different energy that Hannah has than I
do personally I'm much more
um I don't know Labrador Retriever in
the middle of the dog park ready to just
Just Bounce Around and say hi and chat
and Hannah is quite taciturn as a person
actually I mean she's deeply warm on the
inside but she's not just wanting to be
chatty with the person next to her in
the grocery store
um and so just shifting my energy in
that way was so interesting and
something that I hadn't been asked of me
certainly for a long time
um and I just wanted to I wanted to even
build on that in just small ways like
changing my vocal registry or whatever
it was I just kind of wanted to feel the
those differences
um all the way through certainly as a
mom just um playing a stepmom of someone
who isn't thrilled to have you as their
stepmom with something that just really
intrigued me and and was hard for me to
do even personally I wanted to instantly
be friends with and gallery and instead
when we were on screen together we had
to go through this slow laborious
process of building trust but it
certainly led to us building trust as
people so it was wonderful yeah it was
beautiful you guys have great chemistry
in this I love it so much and there's
it's very organic the way you build
towards each other as that you know
dynamic of mother daughter sort of thing
but you know and Gary I loved your
performance I thought you were magnetic
in this um you know you said it yourself
Bailey's very complex and she's held a
lot by her father so you know when he's
out of the picture and she's spiraling
how did you get into that mindset of
somebody's whose identity is crumbling
around them like I can't imagine even
going through something like that I
would not know how to react I would
freak out
it's very
um it is hard to to go into something
um and having never been through
something like that because it is so
specific and so distressing and
traumatic when we were talking about
Bailey before we got into filming there
were so many things just going through
her life story that we could pick out
and that I could find something that
resonated with me or that had happened
in in my life also stories that were
shared from some of our directors shared
some stories um Josh singer and Laura
Dave uh Laura Dave wrote the book and
Josh singers our show runner and they
also had stories of one inspired for
Laura what inspired her
to write Bailey and to write the story
and also for Josh you know just certain
personal stories I really found that um
if we broke down Bailey's emotional
Journey
and took away the context all those
emotions and feelings we had all gone
through similar things so we could I
found that I could get into it that way
just distilling it into specific moments
rather than thinking about a whole
specific
um thing that I needed to relate to if
that makes sense yeah that makes sense
and you know Jennifer I know that you're
a mom and I couldn't help but think that
there are a lot of maternal instincts
popping out in this performance but
Hannah is at a different stage in life
than your own so when you're filming
these scenes with angry's Bailey like
how do you balance what was written for
the character of Hannah with how much of
Jen the mom is added to the role that
was tricky for me and gallery really led
me through that honestly because
um she had such a clear sense of where
we were as a pair
um that I I often found myself
being reminded by her that's right we're
not there yet I'm trying to speed us
into me taking care of you because
that's what I naturally wanted to do and
it was
um and gallery who really held us to
um where we were as a as a team and she
did that by for example not looking at
me the entire first episode except for
once in the car
um so yeah that worked that that was
pretty telling yeah so I wonder if you
guys are a great family unit even with
Nikolai like you have built this family
unit that feels so natural and sweet and
it's just adorable but then you know he
leaves and I'm wondering also like how
did you guys end up you know building
that relationship with him to make it
look like you guys have chemistry like
did he like the way she not looked at
you did he like ghost you guys for a
couple of days and like not talk to you
or something like how did you build that
relationship together the relationship
with Nikolai is that you cannot not
relate to Nikolai he's
so wonderful as as a guy and as an actor
he's such a brilliant actor a brilliant
actor and we always loved when Nikolai
would um would come for a few days to be
with us and then he would disappear
again but it was very clear for me that
the center of the story was
um Bailey and Hannah yeah yeah and um
let's talk about that Victor Garber uh
appearance that was so much fun to see
what was that like for you Jen to like
reconnect with him because I do have to
say that uh as an alias fan in grade 10
I dressed up as Sydney Bristow most
empowering costume ever I just have to
know like what was it like going back to
that and you know it I felt like it was
also one of those things where you know
you did direct an episode of uh Alias
and you are an EP on this so did you
know that did that ever spark something
for you that maybe this I want to do
directing or I want to have an alias
reunion or something
um I'm not in charge of an alias reunion
you'd have to talk to JJ about that
obviously I would be in
um but Victor I talked to every Sunday
so it's not like um you know he thinks
he really is my dad but it's hardly like
there is um there's any confusion about
me talking to him and we have looked for
ways to work together in the last 17
years this Josh came to me and and spoke
to me about it and I could not have been
more excited and really the the ease you
have working with someone again that you
know that well that you love that much
and that you've been opposite that much
is just a beautiful thing it really
makes me believe in Repertory Theater
and and just just repertoires of actors
working to or you know that that idea of
working together as a unit and it makes
me excited for someday getting to work
within Gallery again in any capacity
because I know we will slot in I I could
read her thought and I can be surprised
by it and I trust her with any emotion
that might come up for me and I can't
wait for that to happen again for us
yeah and you know last question for both
of you
um knowing that Laura Dave helped
develop this for TV with hello sunshine
and the fact that we've gotten shows
that are you know on based on books but
they are also built out of the source
material what would you both like would
you where would you imagine Hannah and
Bailey would be knowing what we saw in
the ending would you want to have a
season two because personally I would I
mean I think it's
but for everything I just looked to
Laura Dave I mean we had her on set
every day and and any question I had any
idea any wondering or inkling of what
Bailey's past was like or what her
future might be it just all goes to
Laura Dave and I feel the same way now
it's like I I trust her completely it's
her story it's her characters absolutely
the same if Laura had some crazy idea
great but there are no talks for
anything like that now okay well we'll
have to keep hoping for but I'm so
excited for everyone to watch the show
and thank you so much for your time and
God bless both of you I just I'm such
big fans of you both so I really
appreciate the time today thank you we
love talking thank you thank you